et nous sommes avec aurélie gromaire du
coudray montceaux vice président du
conseil départemental de l'essonne
président de la france vraiment bonsoir
madame merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés guillaume roux secrétaire
départemental de l'unité sgp police 91
bonsoir donc à vous aussi merci d'être
en direct
tout d'abord sur l'airé en renfort avant
d'aller dans le fond du débat 60
gendarmes ce soir de plus à saint chéron
30 policiers à boussy saint antoine ces
deux villes concernées par cette
dramatique actualité c'est ce qui va
ramener le calme
nioro selon vous bah écoutez c'est ce
qui l'a empêché en tout cas on espère
les représailles parce que
malheureusement c'est ça peut être ça
peut être les raisons à la suite de tels
faits nous ce qu'on a besoin de ces des
effectifs permanents non pas des
effectifs éphémère alors oui c'est bien
aujourd'hui d'avoir répondu un parent se
renforce et elle est nécessaire pour
justement essayer de rétablir le 15 mai
puis de le garder surtout c'est ce qui
est important mais ce qui est
souhaitable c'est à l'issue c'est
d'avoir des effectifs supplémentaires
sur tout le département de l'essonne
mais plus particulièrement pour pour
level dire on va y revenir justement sur
cette spécificité malheureusement dans
l'essonne mais tout d'abord mourir à 14
ans pour une stupide histoire de
rivalité on entendu ce témoignage
poignant de ce lycéen très choqué bien
évidemment il ya quelque chose qui ne
tourne plus rond territoire de la
république aurélie gros moi ce soir
si j'ai accepté de m'exprimer sur votre
plateau c'est d'abord pour par
solidarité pour ces deux jeunes victimes
évidemment et je peux dire que nom de
tous les estoniens évidemment de mes
amis maires de l'essonne des élus
départementaux ou encore des
responsables associatifs
notre grande tristesse et m'adresser
aussi ce soir aux familles pour leur
dire que évidemment nous pensons à vous
et aux drames qu'elle vive avec cette
jeune fille ce jeune homme qui ont été
fauchés dans leur première année de
l'adolescence
c'est intolérable c'est inadmissible
et c'est pourtant bien une réalité est
probablement une réalité qui est
explicable pas excusable mais explicable
comment se fait-il aujourd'hui que dans
deux communes de l'essonne petites et
moyennes plutôt tranquille avec que de
telles guerres de bandes aboutissent
aujourd'hui à des mortes et une telle
violence gratuite
il n'y a pas de phénomène spécifique qui
gagne notre pays et on croyait cela
plutôt réservés si je puis dire aux
états unis ou à des quartiers où père
ghettoïser et quand on regarde ces deux
communes ce n'est pas le cas et pour
régler des petits différends de gande on
hésite aujourd'hui pas à tuer
donc pour moi c'est d'une part le
passage à l'acte qui est devenu de plus
en plus banal par rapport à nos jeunes
et il nous fait immanquablement penser
aux réseaux sociaux
là où la haine des fermes les menaces de
nord se banalise et il semble n'y avoir
aucune limite et aujourd'hui à mon sens
internet met de l'huile sur le feu je
pense aussi également en troisième lieu
que le coc vide commencent à peser
lourdement sur les comportements des
adultes 1 ddd des plus âgés aussi qu'ils
sont qui sont relativement enfermés chez
eux sans aucuns liens sociaux mais aussi
mais aussi de notre jeunesse et les
restrictions aujourd'hui de liberté ne
sont plus supportables pour certains et
on oublie aussi de se préoccuper des
autres questions et les moyens de force
de l'autre ce sont les autres questions
les enquêtes pour tresser les jeunes
auteurs la chaîne pénale et les
sanctions contre cette forme de
délinquance
la grande couronne dont fait partie
l'essonne ne reçoit pas les moyens à la
hauteur de nos défis c'est un
département qui est très jeune c'est un
département qui a une population qui
augmente et avec un étalement urbain
donc aujourd'hui les annonces qui ont
été faites de
deux policiers policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires c'est bien il faut
répondre tout de suite aux problèmes qui
se posent
mais ça doit être totalement pérenniser
dans le temps
sermon ne peux pas répondre à un
problème et se dire ça va mieux et on
passe à autre chose on va tâcher de le
prendre tous et beaucoup d'idées dans ce
que vous nous dit on
le débat dure encore un petit peu on va
tenter dé prendre dans l'ordre tout
d'abord un ce chiffre qui parle selon la
direction générale de la police
nationale au moins 80% un des bandes
rivales violentes sont concentrées donc
en ile-de-france alors personnellement
dans l'essonne même s'il ya une gravité
dans ce département en 2020 il y a eu en
france une hausse de 24% des rixes avec
357 affrontements entre bandes
guillaume roux donc c'est clair on se
pose pas la question de savoir si ça
augmenter puisque les faits parlent
d'eux-mêmes aurait dit gros nous parler
des réseaux sociaux est ce que c'est
votre avis aussi la faute aux réseaux
sociaux ce passage à l'acte vous voyez
vous une différence réellement avec les
années internet si j'ose dire la faute
en tout cas ça ça favorise on le sait
très bien les réseaux sociaux sont un
moyen de donner une énorme de notre dame
née énormément de personnes en peu de
temps
oui forcément les réseaux sociaux c'est
très très compliqué à pouvoir à pouvoir
gérer
après bien évidemment pour nous les
collègues par exemple je vais prendre
j'ai parlé de mes collègues du
renseignement parce que toutes ces
bandes là sont connus des services de
police bien évidemment elles sont elles
sont elles sont connues elles sont
identifiés aujourd'hui notre difficulté
à nous et à mes collègues de terrain
c'est de pouvoir anticiper ces faits ces
lettres ces problématiques et c'est pour
ça que j'en reviens à dire que la
solution enfin une des solutions en tout
cas qui pourrait permettre d'anticiper
et puis d'éviter certaines fois que que
ces rixes interviennent et qu'on en
arrive à malheureusement
des morts comme ça a été le cas hier
c'est de pouvoir contrôler ces
regroupements de personnes et pour
pouvoir les contrôler il faut plus de
monde sur le terrain et plus de
fonctionnaires de police et aujourd'hui
le val d'yerres qui comprend trois
communes brunoy mangeront de draveil n'a
pas d'unité d'appui de gsp août bst ce
que peut avoir corbeil essonnes evry ou
juvisy ou massy ou d'autres communes
comme sainte geneviève des bois donc
c'est très important de pouvoir
rapidement maîtres du monde sur le
terrain ça c'est un premier pas après
forcément toutes les solutions la police
met à plat pour endiguer malheureusement
ce phénomène là qui existe depuis très
longtemps c'est pas le coc vide et
peut-être une solution locaux vides et
pardon et peut-être une un problème
aujourd'hui
mais en tout cas c'est pas c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui que ce phénomène existe
évidemment ça fait 20 ans que je suis
sur le département de l'essonne
et malheureusement ce phénomène de rixe
entre bandes j'ai toujours connu
par contre le niveau de violence a
augmenté sa c'est ça c'est indéniable
aujourd'hui c'est des armes à feu
c'est des couteaux donc on est là pour
faire pour faire mal c'est ce qu'ils
disent mais eux ont pu malheureusement
et on le voit encore hier et avant-hier
on allait à saint chéron dans l'essonne
où cette collégienne a trouvé la mort
charles beaudry s'est rendu sur place
notre reporter il a recueilli le
témoignage d'une habitante évidemment
choquée comme le reste de la population
sur place écoutez je suis né ici donc ça
fait trente saisons que des gens
viennent ici parce que c'est réputé
calme tout logiquement après bon bah ça
peut arriver qu'il ya des petites
bagarres mais à ce point là c'est vrai
que c'est très très rare
il ya déjà eu des des rixes avec des
armes et pas de pas de blessé grave on
va dire de mort malheureusement ça nous
a choqués surtout que moi je connais je
connais son frère et sa mère de
wilkinson ouais ça m'a choqué ça rassure
que les forces de l'ordre passé c'est
vrai que quand des convois un petit
attroupement bas ça ça nous ça nous fait
peur aussi sur le coup et tout ce qui
s'est passé donc saaq les voir circuler
salutations et aurélie gros cette mère
de famille qui nous dira en substance
que nous disait guillaume roux et vous
aussi d'ailleurs on a toujours connu ces
phénomènes de violence mais pas à ce
point là
comment les expliquez guillaume roux
nous disait tout à l'heure que ces gens
là finalement ils étaient identifiés sur
les réseaux sociaux
qui sont-ils quel est leur profil ce
sont des jeunes des enfants même ils
sont quoi délaissés par leurs parents
ils traînent dans la rue expliqué nous
un petit peu le profil type c'est en
inde deux de ces jeunes
juste pour préciser tout à l'heure quand
j'ai parlé du coc vide je ne pense pas
que ce soit le coc vide qui entraîne ce
type de 2,2 problème est que les
augmentations de deux rixes dans nos
territoires ne sont pas dues au coup
vite par contre je pense qu'on se
préoccupe beaucoup moins nous élus
locaux les responsables
on ne se préoccupe beaucoup moins de ces
sujets-là entendre qu vide et
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un vrai travail
engagé sur nos territoires sert les
territoires de grande couronne après
pour vous parler des jeunes parler des
jeunes on a parlé des réseaux sociaux
c'est qu'on a des jeunes qui sont
énormément sur les réseaux sociaux
le coc vide encore une fois n'arrange
rien qui aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
faudrait une réponse sur ces réseaux
sociaux
quand vous voyez une police réel des
réseaux sociaux je sais que ça existe je
suis au courant mais je pense qu'il
faudrait accentuer la recherche sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est insensé qu'on puisse diffuser
aujourd'hui des appels au meurtre
alors qu on a par exemple vu les grands
réseaux sociaux fermer les comptes du
président des états unis parce que ces
propos devenez incitateurs à la
rébellion
aujourd'hui on ferme le compte de donald
trump mais on n'agit pas sur ces jeunes
qui y qui se s'étale sur les réseaux
sociaux et se jette en pleine figure des
propos haineux
aujourd'hui on n'a aucun moyen d'agir
alors moi je demande au responsable
d'internet des réseaux sociaux gafa
d'agir sur ce problème là c'est
essentiel à mon sens on rirait si je
venais bouger je découpe en parler des
idées
voilà je le répète ce sont des enfants
ils n'ont pas des parents ces enfants
qui serait quand même responsable un
petit peu aussi toujours demander à
l'état oui évidemment l'état une
responsabilité surveiller la sécurité
mais les parents auront on n'en parle
pas dans cette affaire bien sûr bien sûr
ils ont des parents est à mon sens mode
six mères de famille de quatre enfants
donc je suis une mère aussi donc je peux
me mettre à la place des parents un
enfant de 13 ans et 14 ans n'a rien à
faire à traîner dans les rues en bandes
armées c'est ça devient ça devient
relativement hallucinant effectivement
le problème des parents et de
l'éducation à domicile mais on sait très
bien qu'une pour une partie de ces
jeunes là l'absence de parents c'est à
dire qu'ils soient en capacité de
pouvoir s'occuper d'eux et est souvent
souvent le cas donc ça n'excuse rien
parce que moi je trouve qu'il n'ya pas
d' excuses devant de tels actes par
contre effectivement certains maires ont
pris des décisions quant aux aides
sociales sur sur les parents dont les
enfants commettraient des des délits
important je pense qu'à un moment donné
il faudra réfléchir conjointement tous
ensemble pour que la responsabilité des
parents soient soient mises en avant
dans dans ce type de problème bien au
dessus on est on est d'accord les
parents et ont leur responsabilité et on
peut pas toujours dire que c'est l'état
les enseignants le manque de culture le
manque de 1 lissiers je ne suis pas en
train de dire ça moi j'essaye de donner
la réponse politique
or je ne suis pas dans les familles mais
effectivement à un moment de livres
après avoir une réponse très claire avec
ses parents qui n'assument pas leur rôle
et à ce moment-là peut-être leur couper
les aides comme l'ont fait certains
maires dans
comme il ya aussi la chaîne pénale dont
vous parliez aurélie gros tout à l'heure
guillaume roux beaucoup de réactions
évidemment après ces drames beaucoup
parlent de la primo délinquants ça c'est
à dire ses premiers actes qui selon
certains ne seraient pas assez
sanctionné donne un sentiment d'impunité
c'est une partie du problème selon vous
également
ça fait partie la réponse pénale adaptée
aujourd'hui elle doit forcément de
forcément être sur une table pour en
discuter parce que c'est un vrai
problème
effectivement aujourd'hui ce phénomène
de bandes qui vont le voir le niveau de
violence a augmenté
il faut absolument de trouver une
réponse adaptée une réponse pénale
adaptée pour pour ces jeunes parce que
le problème c'est que ce qui est ce qui
est un petit peu énervant c'est que nous
nous policiers et syndicats on le
dénonce depuis très longtemps on le voit
de toute façon que cette nouvelle
génération cette nouvelle délinquance à
paris depuis un petit moment voilà on le
voit bien aujourd'hui les collègues qui
subissent des guets-apens avec des jets
des jets de cocktails molotov ou des
tirs de mortier ce sont des jeunes du
même âge d'ailleurs ce qui était sans
doute hier dans la bagarre peuvent
participer à ce genre de ce genre de
faits donc voilà ça c'est des choses
qu'on avait déjà dénoncé depuis
longtemps et j'ai peur que j'ai pas
encore une fois on ne faisait pas pris
au sérieux on n'est pas pris le
phénomène au sérieux on a pensé que
c'était quelque chose qui pouvait se
régler tout seul absolument pas et je
pense encore une fois que ça ça passe
par une discussion et la réponse pénale
adaptée pour ce genre de faits en est
une en tout cas avec après
l'augmentation des effectifs de police
parce que encore une fois je le répète
c'est très importante pour nous sur le
terrain de pouvoir endiguer ce genre de
situation je dire la présence policière
est là toujours dissuader dans les
quartiers vous passez en bois la police
aujourd'hui malheureusement il ya des
quartiers il ya des zones où on la voit
moins et le val d'isère c'est le cas
parce que il nous manque des effectifs
alors sur le département en général ça
c'est sûr mais encore plus sur le val
d'yerres et malheureusement hier c'est
un drame qui nous fait encore parler de
ça alors il est grand le mot de la fin
la peur de la police mais aussi au final
la peur des condamnations vraiment
sévère de la police est question et la
réponse pénale sur ces jeunes-là et
essentiel je pense que alors moi je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas une partisane
d'envoyer ces jeunes dans les prisons
puisqu'on sait que ce n'est pas la
solution mais des maisons d'éducation où
il sera envoyé
purgera une peine pour vraiment pour
mineurs où il n'y a aucun mélange avec
avec des adultes me semblerait très
adapté on a un grand nombre de casernes
qui ont été fermés on pourrait les
transformer pour ces jeunes là
aujourd'hui les jeunes qui ont qui
commettent des faits ont un sentiment de
surpuissance parce qu'ils savent très
bien au bout du compte ça n'ira pas très
loin donc les policiers font leur
travail prennent des risques
c'est à dire qu'ils vont au front ils
vont aller au contact de la population
souvent en sous-effectif et par la suite
on sait que la réponse pénale ne va pas
suivre derrière aujourd'hui c'est toute
la chaîne
la chaîne de pénale qui est à revoir et
effectivement les effectifs donnée par
monsieur darmanin hier aux puces sont
les seuls doivent être pérennisés
car vous parliez du taux du val d'yerres
mais c'est sur l'ensemble de l'essonne
qu'il y a un problème d'effectif
moi je le vois dans ma commune on peut
pas dire que les gendarmes soient très
bien doté en effectif et clairement il
faut que la chaîne pénale il réponse
il ya une réponse pénale à chaque acte
de ces jeunes mères parce que tu es
jeune qui se balade avec avec des armes
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas tolérable
merci bois est dans un sentiment
d'impunité
merci beaucoup à tous les 2 aurélie
grolier auront d'avoir été avec nous
d'avoir accepté ce décryptage ce soir